-But, you know what?
Today is Friday.
You know, let's kick off
the weekend with something fun.
You know?
Let's -- let's
catch up on some e-mails.
-Right.
-It's our first week back.
-Yeah.
-You know, I want to thank
everybody
for what a great week
of shows we had here.
I want to...
-It's wonderful to be back.
-Maybe I'll send out
some thank you notes.
-Really?
-If you guys...?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I do them right now?
Do you mind
if I do it right now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much.
-Wow.
-James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Wow.
-He's happy to be back.
-Hey, a little rusty.
He's a little rusty.
[ Laughter ]
-Eh!
[ Gentle piano music plays ]
-Thank you,
Bed, Bath and Beyond
for dressing up
as Spirit Halloween this year.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, it's beyond.
[ Gentle piano music plays]
-Thank you,
Las Vegas sphere
for looking like Epcot
going through an emo phase.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As angry emo ]
Talk to me.
You're not my real dad.
[ Gentle piano music plays ]
Normal voice ] Thank you,
TSA body scanners
for making me feel like
I can't get on the plane
unless I do the "M" in "YMCA."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And pat down.
[ Gentle piano music plays ]
-Thank you,
fish sticks
for being perfect for anyone
who ate a mozzarella stick
and thought if only
this tasted like carp.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ I can dream, can't I dream? ♪
[ Gentle piano music plays ]
Thank you,
Clear umbrellas
for pranking the rain into
thinking it's going to get me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal clangs ]
I love you.
You're the best.
I love you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
[ Indistinct ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hahaha!
-All right.
[ Slow piano music plays ]
Thank you,
Hershey's Halloween
variety packs
for single handedly
keeping Mr. Goodbar alive.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Applause ]
Wah, wah, wah?
-I'm looking for Mr. Goodbar.
-I don't see much him.
-I'm looking for him.
[ Gentle piano music plays ]
Thank you,
trying to help my children
with their homework for being
a tough but fair reminder
of why I got into comedy.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my "Thank You Notes."